[Música]
un 24 de agosto pero de 1991 ucrania
proclamó su independencia de la entonces
unión soviética ucrania pasó a ser
entonces un estado independiente y
democrático el 24 de agosto pero del
2022 ucrania conmemora su independencia
con discretos actos como los que ustedes
ven en sus imágenes pero también se
cumplen seis meses del inicio de la
invasión de rusia a ucrania
esta guerra que estaba aparentemente
incipiente desde el 2014 ahora se
muestra estancada y con la amenaza de
extenderse en el tiempo
desde primera hora de la mañana el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr zielinski
se dirigió a la nación en medio del
temor de nuevos ataques rusos advirtió
que su país no iniciará negociaciones
con teniendo miedo entre la población
y maneras ya esta ley es para nosotros
el fin de la guerra solíamos decir paz
ahora decimos victoria no buscaremos un
entendimiento mutuo con un terrorista
aunque entendemos el idioma ruso que
vinieron a defender mientras mataban a
miles de personas que vinieron a
liberadas
[Música]
seis meses después del inicio de la
invasión podemos hacer un balance de lo
que deja este conflicto en sus pantallas
pueden ver el territorio ucraniano en
color amarillo vemos las regiones de don
jet-ski lugansk que desde el 2014
estaban en manos de separatistas pro
rusos tras el inicio de la invasión la
ocupación de estas dos regiones se ha
ido extendiendo y rusia ya controla
prácticamente toda la región del dom
vázquez conformada por donets y lugansk
que ustedes lo ven en color anaranjado
también en color amarillo vemos la
península de crimea un poco más al sur
que fue anexada rusia en el 2014 y que
es un hecho que no tiene reconocimiento
internacional en color rojo ustedes
bueno pueden ver el territorio que ha
sido conquistado hasta el día de hoy por
las tropas rusas también pueden ver aquí
en la capital que se mantiene
resguardada por en alerta ante una
posible incursión rusa lo mismo que el
asediado puerto de odessa en el sur y en
el este pueden ver la ciudad de kharkiv
la segunda ciudad de más importante más
importancia en ucrania que ya está en
manos de los cosas
pues así es como está la situación en
terreno ahora veamos entonces las cifras
para dimensionar el tamaño de este
conflicto hasta ahora según el alto
comisionado de la onu para los derechos
humanos unos cinco mil quinientos
catorce civiles aproximadamente han
fallecido también unos siete mil 890
aproximadamente han resultado heridos en
los diferentes combates y bombardeos
ante el avance ruso parte de la
comunidad internacional de fuera un poco
a poco imponiendo sanciones a rusia
veamos algunas de ellas como para hacer
un rápido repaso de ellas por ejemplo
veamos las que ha impuesto la unión
europea impuso sanciones a cerca de 100
entidades rusas a 1200 personas de
nacionalidad rusa
351 personas que eran integrantes o son
integrantes del parlamento ruso a 30
reconocidos oligarcas rusos también le
fueron impuestas algunas sanciones
también impuso restricciones al acceso
de los rusos a las vías terrestres al
espacio aéreo ya
también a los puertos marítimos de la
unión europea suspendió la emisión de
varios medios de comunicación entre
ellos
rt y sputnik principalmente en el
continente europeo y bueno también lo
evidenciamos aquí en américa latina'
asimismo restringió o suspendió la
importación de oro y hierro petróleo y
gas en el ámbito financiero suspendió
las transacciones financieras y rusia
fue excluida del sistema swift
esto nos llevó por lo menos hasta ahora
a que rusia diera marcha atrás en esta
operación militar especial como ellos
han calificado en el kremlin esta
incursión militar en territorio
ucraniano que también es un desastre
humanitario veamos algunas de las cifras
desde el inicio de la invasión más de
10,5 millones de ucranianos han
abandonado el país provocando una
verdadera crisis humanitaria en europa
de s 10,5 millones de los que
abandonaron el país unos 6 millones son
hoy en día refugiados ya tienen el
estatus de refugiado en alguno de los
países a los que han llegado la mayoría
de ellos llegaron a polonia allí
llegaron cerca de 12 millones a alemania
también recibió cerca de un millón de
eucar ania nosotros han llegado a
hungría eslovaquia rumanía moldavia que
son países vecinos turquía italia españa
portugal y otros han ido un poco más
allá han llegado hasta eeuu a través de
la frontera con mexico han llegado
también a canadá incluso hasta israel
bueno pues muy bien esto es a grandes
rasgos lo que deja hasta ahora esta
guerra en ucrania cuando ya se cumplen
seis meses del inicio de la invasión por
parte de las tropas rusas tema que
entonces analizamos hoy en el debate de
france 24 para conversar sobre este tema
hemos invitado a iván catón académico en
relaciones internacionales también es
experto en geopolítica él se encuentra
en la ciudad de santo domingo en
república dominicana y desde buenos
aires en argentina saludamos allí a
gonzalo fiore él es analista
internacional docente de la universidad
anáhuac en querétaro y también es
becario doctoral de conicet en argentina
les recuerdo que ustedes también hacen
parte de esta conversación pueden dejar
sus preguntas sus comentarios sus
impresiones en las redes sociales
estamos en twitter en instagram en
facebook en donde nos encuentran como
france24 bajo ese i arroba santi logo
que es mi cuenta personal la etiqueta
para que dejen los comentarios por lo
menos en twitter o en instagram es
numeral el debate efe 24 en youtube
también pueden seguir nuestra señal en
streaming dejar los comentarios en el
chat en vivo y aprovecho para saludar a
las personas que nos están oyendo a
través del podcast todos nuestros
contenidos ya están disponibles en
nuestras plataformas en el podcast en
spotify deezer y tienen
bueno pues tenemos muchos temas para
analizar el día de hoy comienza entonces
dándole la bienvenida a iván en la
ciudad de santo domingo iván gracias por
acompañarnos punto de partida para esta
discusión
su balance de lo que dejan estos seis
meses de invasión de rusia al territorio
ucraniano como para tener una
perspectiva general de su opinión antes
de empezar a profundizar en los
diferentes temas
el balance para mí es que estamos en el
inicio de una nueva etapa geopolítica de
la
de la especie humana lo que vendría a
hacer cómo llamaría immanuel wallerstein
en esa
evolución cíclica de los periodos
hegemónicos y donde la guerra en ucrania
que muestra cómo hemos llegado a un
punto en el cual los seres humanos
volvemos a perder
un espacio donde tener la paz como un
referente y la mejor convivencia de los
seres humanos es una guerra que la está
perdiendo la humanidad de su conjunto
esa es la evaluación que podemos hacer
no solamente con las catástrofes hemos
estado viendo en términos humanitarios
sino también los efectos colaterales en
términos
económicos
humanitarios que está teniendo a miles
de kilómetros de distancia más allá de
donde están es donde está ocurriendo el
conflicto bélico
gonzalo le doy la bienvenida a usted se
encuentra en la ciudad de buenos aires-
gracias por acompañarnos a punto de
partida también la misma pregunta su
balance de estos seis meses de invasión
del territorio
ucraniano por parte de las tropas rusas
pero un conflicto que venía abierto por
lo menos desde el año 2014
así es bueno antes que nada muchas
gracias por invitarme al programa y
compartir el espacio con el colega de
república dominicana es coincidía con
con los que escuchaba del colega y
pienso inmediatamente lo que decía
éramos de rotterdam de nuevo que las
guerras nadie las ganas y acá estamos
viendo un caso muy concreto al respecto
de esto donde por un lado en lo bélico y
pareciera que está en una especie de
punto muerto estancado donde no se saben
muy bien cuáles son los objetivos rusos
a mediano o largo plazo donde tampoco
ucrania puede recuperar las zonas que ya
como que ya tomó rusia y donde tenemos
además la cuestión de las sanciones
económicas bueno podemos entrar en eso
que junto a la catástrofe humanitaria
por supuesto los muertos por su cuerpo
los 10 millones de refugiados
reaccionaba al principio también tenemos
una catástrofe económica a nivel global
donde la situación es realmente muy
complicada de carácter y al mediano a
largo plazo todo indicaría que esto es
una guerra que recién estamos comenzando
y también coincido con con el colega
respecto de él que estamos viendo
claramente hoy una un paso de la
gravitación del poder global de
occidente a otra la otra región no
debería entre pronto vamos a analizar
ese punto también gonzalo quiero
comenzar preguntándole a ustedes dos
para armar el rompecabezas de lo que es
esta situación este conflicto allí
continúa entonces con gonzalo para hacer
la ronda la inversa pero la pregunta
también iván la puede complementar en su
respuesta y es si llevamos seis meses de
este conflicto de esta invasión desde el
2014 esta guerra viene andando ahí en el
este de ucrania es porque claramente la
diplomacia no ha funcionado
en este conflicto que evaluación puede
hacer usted gonzalo de ese aspecto de la
diplomacia por parte de la unión europea
eeuu la comunidad internacional para
sentar a ucrania y a rusia a dialogar o
por lo menos conversar con rusia
conversar computing para entender
exactamente que lo que buscan ellos con
esta invasión del este de ucrania que
por muchas advertencias que hubo muy
pocos creyeron que fuera a llevarse a
cabo hasta que sorpresivamente ese 24 de
febrero entraron las tropas rusas
claramente como en la diplomacia no ha
dado los resultados esperados porque
tenemos las pruebas ya estamos ante el
conflicto bélico y comenzó las cremas ya
no lo pudo parar no pudo intentar a las
partes inclusive volvió a fracasar tras
el comienzo del conflicto bélico cuando
hubo algunos intentos inmediatos por
erdogán por turquía donde intentaban
tentar a putin y aceleró y para dialogar
para tratar de llegar a algún acuerdo de
paz eso también para casos
y a su vez creo que también tengo una
mirada bastante crítica de las
instituciones occidentales de cómo
intentaron contener de alguna manera el
comienzo del conflicto y no lo lograron
esto lo va a ver lo han advertido
autores como si tengo lo advertido
verdad y ver lo advertido el mismo henry
kissinger por ejemplo de que si
occidente seguía actuando como venía
actuando era muy difícil evitar que
rusia reacciones de esta manera también
lo entonces creo que es importante
también pensar de cara al futuro sobre
todo no y rever de alguna manera cuáles
son los mecanismos que se pueden tener
para poder entrar que estos conflictos
se hagan a mayores
y van usted menciona en su mencionó en
su intervención anterior una nueva etapa
de la geopolítica
internacional en ese orden de ideas ya
que la diplomacia aquí pues claramente
está mostrando un gran fracaso para
poder dialogar o acercar las partes para
poder empezar a buscar mecanismos para
una solución de este conflicto en esa
nueva estructura geopolítica entonces la
diplomacia en donde puede quedar también
la diplomacia es necesario que tenga una
reestructuración para poder hacer frente
a los conflictos de hoy en día que vemos
que muchos de los que participan en
estos conflictos claramente no le
importa lo que digan organismos
internacionales como la unión europea a
un organismo como naciones unidas o
acnur que hable de una crisis
humanitaria
estamos ante una gran transición
geopolítica que se orden que se
estableció a partir de la segunda guerra
mundial no es el que representa
genuinamente los intereses que estamos
viendo en todo el planeta por eso hay
que ver que hay incidencia de parte
tanto de rusia de china
como de turquía como de la india
qué
políticamente hablando cómo podemos
tener una gran influencia
en un organismo como naciones unidas- si
estos actores se alinean más allá de lo
que se ha establecido como un orden
internacional que fue diseñado por dos
potencias que una de ellas la heredó la
federación rusa y otra que evidentemente
como es china tiene una gran incidencia
económica y política y por otro lado la
india que toma distancia y aprovecha la
situación para tener una mayor
incidencia y una turquía que está en la
otan pero no está en la unión europea
que tiene problemas con los kurdos pero
que tiene un acercamiento con rusia pero
que al mismo tiempo tiene acercamiento
con irán
es que el orden establecido desde la
segunda guerra mundial parece que está
caduco es el logan
aquí en selenski
señala para poder llegar con el
secretario general de naciones unidas
con guterres para que se pueda permitir
la salida de alimentos
desde ucrania es decir que un actor que
es criticado por su forma de actuar
políticamente ahora se convierte en el
interlocutor válido
evidentemente es un nuevo rey sí y en
ese orden de ideas pues la diplomacia
también tiene que
reorganizarse de acuerdo a las
estructuras y al orden mundial en el que
estamos centrando en gonzalo retomó
parte de lo que ha dicho y ban el
menciona varios países que están tomando
unas posiciones muy claras en este en
este conflicto en esta situación que se
ha presentado a lo largo de estos seis
meses quiero que veamos un análisis
rápido de países como por ejemplo china
que ha evitado criticar a rusia por esta
invasión un país como belarús país
hermano de ucrania pero resultó ser un
país digamos bypass para poder invadir
el norte y tratar de que las tropas
rusas llegaran ayer desde el norte
sirvió para eso y ha apoyado a rusia en
esta invasión india que sigue hablando
con rusia comerciando y turquía que ya
pues iván nos daba un adelanto de lo que
ha jugado en este escenario tratando de
ser un poco como el mediador
sí es muy interesante lo que lo que
decía iván y comparto que claramente hoy
estamos ante un cambio real y profundo
que le vamos a poder dar recién creo a
mediano plazo nuestros procesos llevan
tiempo y no se puede poner un corte
temporal específico tienen que ver cómo
se desarrollan los acontecimientos pero
que estamos viendo una transformación
desde la gravitación del poder global
hacia otra región hoy estamos viendo una
nueva etapa creo del multipolarismo hoy
estamos viendo una etapa diferente donde
países emergentes como nombraron india
por supuesto china y turquía están
teniendo otro rol y además tampoco hay
que dejar de lado que a su vez están
dando otros conflictos paralelos en la
guerra educan ya por supuesto tiene toda
la atención tiene todos los focos lo que
nos ocupa ahora pero a su vez y que
hablan las claras de una inestabilidad
global al mundo cada vez más complejo
impredecible se van dando otros
conflictos por ejemplo lo que sucede en
taiwán con china
en lo que sucede también la región del
indo pacífico entonces todo lo que está
sucediendo en esas regiones
van para leer en paralelo y ahora las
claras de un cambio concreto sistémico
diría de cara al futuro las preguntas y
lo que se conoce en relaciones
internacionales como la trampa de tus
ideo la maldición de tu sigue es decir
cuando una potencia declinante está
cayendo y una potencia está en ascenso
se produce un conflicto no entonces está
por verse si efectivamente ese conflicto
más global se produce pero todo
indicaría que esto va para largo plazo
europa misma está preparada para
conflicto a largo plazo ya sea tanto
entre un gran y roche como un tercero
estado
y bueno estamos haciendo este programa
justamente por el marco de estos seis
meses que ha durado hasta ahora este
conflicto desde el mundo occidental los
análisis y los reportes que llegan a
través de los medios de comunicación es
que esta es una guerra que se está
volviendo una guerra muy lenta que en
cierta forma está estancada que tanto
tiene esto de estrategia por parte de
rusia para hacer una estrategia digamos
de agotamiento y tal vez lo que está
sorprendiendo es que rusia parece que
tiene toda la paciencia del mundo para
continuar con este conflicto abierto y
no tiene prisa por terminar lo rápido o
darle un fin abrupto pese a las
sanciones internacionales que piensa
usted
hay un elemento que quizás estamos
pasando por alto y que lo advertía el
propio kissinger no es saber ante el
realismo político
evidentemente ucrania
militarmente no le va a ganar a rusia
y sin el apoyo de la otan
y de occidente
ucrania no podría aguantar
la embestida rusa a pesar
del buen ejército de ucrania tiene
rusia está contando con el apoyo de
actores importantes del mundo
contemporáneo como es china y rúsia
no podemos tampoco
subestimar
como rusia
puede tener
acercamientos con potencias regionales
como turquía e irán a pesar de haber
violado flagrantemente el derecho
internacional
todo esto como se ha advertido se podía
evitar
rusia si estaba consciente
de que si eeuu
no ponía
un detente
a la ampliación de la otan por lo que
ellos advertían que era una amenaza para
su seguridad
y va a verse involucrada
en una guerra como la que hoy se
encuentra que ya hace más de cuatro años
como te referías lo vimos reflejado y
reflejado en ucrania y la situación del
donbass
y
gonzalo en este momento en esta altura
seis meses después del inicio de la
invasión es posible entender un poco más
a profundidad qué es lo que busca rusia
qué es lo que quiere putin con esta
invasión
bueno en primer lugar lo que estaba más
claro y lo que quiero claro que putin
quería prácticamente anexar toda la
región del estero quizás no al estar
pero sí darle otro estatus a la región
del este todo lo que tiene que ver con
el donbass por lo que se viene viendo
bueno rusia ha avanzado inclusive en
otras en otras regiones y ahora también
está una situación de tensión
ambivalente respecto de el puerto de el
puerto debe está 90 usted pero eso es lo
estrictamente militar no pero
políticamente no está en claro qué es lo
que busca rusia que lo viene rusia
depende por supuesto desde donde uno se
pare y uno analice es probable que rusia
busque un cambio de régimen en ucrania
algún gobierno que le responda de alguna
manera más amigable rusia y no tanto y
no hacia el occidente por supuesto por
toda la sensibilidad particular que
tiene
para para rusia en este contexto
entonces creo que hay que estar muy
atento también a lo que va a suceder
políticamente hacia adentro de ucrania
por un lado y por el otro por el otro
lado creo que también retomó lo que
decía iván está claro que lograría sin
el apoyo de occidente y tiene la fuerza
de notar no puede repetir contra el
poderío militar ruso y también que rusia
al ser una operación militar especial y
no una guerra técnicamente hablando
puede parecer óptimo pero tiene ahí
algunas particularidades es importante
que atender tampoco está poniendo
absolutamente todo el ejército todo el
poderío bélico sobre sobre el terreno y
el mismo putin lo dijo rusia puede puede
esperar puede aguantar
europa también se está preparando para
un conflicto un conflicto largo putin
hace algunos meses hizo un paralelismo
con pedro grande que tuvo 21 guerra
entonces siendo bueno se puede rusia
puede esperar puede aguantar y por eso
está que respondiendo lo que
a bastantes no no no tiene no parece
tener ningún apuro para ponerle un fin
abrupto a la guerra
iván y cómo están las cosas en este
momento y entendiendo un poco la
dinámica de las situaciones que se han
presentado en estos seis meses resulta
muy paradójico ver que putin inició
según declaraciones del kremlin esta
invasión precisamente por esa expansión
constante de la otan desde los años 90
que era un reclamo que hacía moscú
constantemente a esta organización pero
ahora el escenario es aún más paradójico
la otan se extendió hasta las mismas
fronteras de rusia con la incorporación
de suecia y finlandia y con la llegada
de aún más efectivos y más equipo
militar a países como estonia letonia y
lituania es decir la otan ya llegó al
mismo punto de la frontera
rosa
cómo evaluó usted y qué análisis hace de
lo que ha hecho la otan que muchos
esperaban que los ejércitos de la otan
entraran al territorio que daña no y no
ha sido así
hay una realidad y es que putin lo que
hizo fue
que la otan se ampliará aún más
pero quizás un elemento que desde
occidente pasamos por alto y que de una
manera u otra nos permite poder entender
mejor la mentalidad de la rusa es que
siempre rusia
ha sido inválida y siempre ha tenido sus
temores y en el momento en el cual
la otan comienza a ampliarse
teniendo una buena relación con rusia
porque no olvidemos la famosa reunión de
seguridad que se llevó a cabo en berlín
cuando putin era el primer ministro y me
vería era el presidente de rusia donde
el putting se quejaba de que cuál era la
necesidad de la ampliación de la otan
cuando la propia rusia la federación
rusa había mostrado interés
en estar cercana a occidente
entonces la geopolítica demuestra que
cuando usted no está en un almuerzo en
la mesa es porque usted es parte del
menú no es simple paranoia de parte de
los productos el tema de la otan en un
momento en el cual la humanidad
pudo haber aprovechado
para hacer una mayor
interdependencia con elementos que
permitieran un mayor nivel de
crecimiento en la población lo que se ha
hecho es fortalecer el complejo
militar-industrial y esto no lo podemos
pasar por al mirar mientras la mayoría
de nuestros gobiernos en américa latina
ven los informes de la cepal de cómo van
nuestras economías a ser afectadas por
la guerra en ucrania y como en el propio
estados unidos y en la unión europea la
inflación ha aumentado
hay una industria que le está yendo muy
bien que es el complejo
militar-industrial a parte del sector
energético
claro importante ese punto que esas
industrias benefician a varios países
tanto en europa como en nuestro
continente bueno por decir un nombre
exacto eeuu que tiene todo una industria
militar que poner en marcha después del
conflicto en afganistán y después de la
pandemia de kobe 19 vamos a preguntarles
ahora a los dos por las consecuencias de
esta guerra ya lo veíamos a lo largo de
estos seis meses desabastecimiento de
granos y cereales la falta de suministro
de gas y petróleo para europa la falta
de fertilizantes en el mundo el alcance
que tiene esto es a nivel global la
inflación que vemos en los países de
américa latina y prácticamente a nivel
mundial también es parte en consecuencia
de esa de ese conflicto en ucrania el
alcance de esto hasta dónde nos va a
llevar esto vaya a arrastrarnos a una
crisis
internacional de gran tamaño gonzález
usted cómo lo ve
bueno creo que hoy todo lo que uno viene
viendo creo que entiende lamentablemente
a esto a una crisis internacional a gran
escala una gran crisis sistémica hay
algunos datos para ilustrar esto bueno
lo que decía la escasez energética la
cuestión alimentaria hecha estos días
importantes funcionarios europeos ya
están hablando de que se vienen 10
inviernos duros en europa
por la escasez de energéticos e que
también en la política europea está
viendo un conflicto a largo plazo el
mismo macrón decía hoy que el punto que
viene es un mundo donde se terminó la
etapa de la abundancia tipo macro
textual refiriéndose a toda esta
problemática de escasez eeuu los últimos
tres trimestres sufrió contracciones en
el bebé y es decir que técnicamente está
en recesión estamos con la infracción al
tanto de los últimos 50 años y con un
conflicto que creo que el peor hoy que
se extienda a terceros países no solo
por supuesto por lo que esto implicaría
en términos de humanitarios en términos
humanos sino por también lo que
implicaría en términos económicos está
claro que a medida que se vaya a
profundizar hay más países más países
vayan participando de esto la crisis
económica va a ser cada vez más profunda
todo indicaría que
lamentablemente el mediano plazo no va a
aminorar sino más bien todo lo contrario
se va a provocar claro y bueno otro
punto importante para analizar es la
crisis humanitaria que ha dejado estos 6
meses de guerra en ucrania yo ya daba
algunas de las cifras la cantidad de
personas refugiadas o que tuvieron que
huir de ucrania para salvar sus vidas de
los combates y de los bombardeos sobre
todo en el este de ucrania lo que vemos
aquí es que cada tanto hay una crisis o
un nuevo escenario de crisis humanitario
si no era ucrania entonces era siria la
crisis de los rohingya la crisis en el
mediterráneo durante la etapa de hoy
época de verano en el verano boreal
constantemente están saliendo crisis
humanitarias y la comunidad
internacional cada vez parece tener
menos fuerzas para poder combatir o
poder
llevar a cabo algún tipo de ayuda para
para solucionar este tipo de crisis y
solucionar los problemas de raíz se nos
están agotando las ideas y las
capacidades para afrontar estas crisis
humanitarias desplazados hambrunas y
personas muriendo en el mediterráneo' en
los pasos fronterizos
algo que nos enseña la historia es que
cuando se dan grandes cambios en la
humanidad no todos los líderes políticos
o las personas que dirigen los países
están a la altura de las circunstancias
históricas que se puedan estar viviendo
por eso vuelvo a recalcar de que esta es
una guerra que pudo haber sido evitada y
que desgraciadamente esa comunidad
internacional en un espacio en el cual
se pudo haber hecho grandes proezas en
cuanto a trabajar el tema del medio
ambiente en cuanto a reducir el número
de personas
y que tienen que salir de sus países por
situaciones climáticas de guerra tenemos
gonzalo más de 200 millones de personas
que tienen que huir de sus países por
conflictos internos entonces estamos
echando de un lado lo que las futuras
generaciones necesitan que es un
ambiente más favorable en cuanto al
cuidado del planeta tierra todo eso se
está echando a un lado estamos perdiendo
de vista el compromiso con tener
y mayor seguridad
en los países nuestros y donde miles de
personas mueren por la delincuencia
común por ejemplo en américa latina'
esto afecta a más de un 15% del producto
interno bruto porque la delincuencia
mayormente asesina a personas jóvenes y
los efectos colaterales que esto tiene
estamos hablando de que no tenemos ni
soberanía y seguridad alimentaria de que
estamos en un proceso en el cual la
humanidad a pesar de toda la tecnología
está involucionando podrán los líderes
políticos que hablan tanto de democracia
fortalecer la democracia después de
haber salido de la cob y 19 endeudados y
ahora con unos precios energéticos que
desbordan los ingresos que tiene el
fisco
podemos nosotros contribuir a la
democracia en una situación como ésta
que no importa el presidente que llegue
al poder podrá resolver las urgencias
que esta guerra nos ha presentado parece
desgraciadamente
que los políticos que nos han estado
dirigiendo en el mundo esas manos claro
en vez en la zona del planeta no estaban
pensando en la humanidad
parece que ese es el escenario iván
gonzalo esto también ha servido para
afianzar precisamente discursos
políticos sobre todo desde el lado de
moscú y también desde kiev desde el
gobierno ucraniano que análisis puede
uno hacer de ese discurso de rusia
encontró un nuevo enemigo para ponerlo
en el escenario internacional y también
para ucrania en cierta forma como que
sirvió para afianzar un poco más ese
sentimiento esa identidad de nación que
a ucrania le ha costado tanto construir
en estas tres décadas de nación
independiente siendo esclava pero
también muy permeada por rusia ya lo
veíamos todo el tema de lingüístico la
mitad del país no habla ni siquiera
ucraniano que se puede decir sobre estos
discursos políticos
y sin ninguna duda es un tema muy
interesante para tener en cuenta a la
hora de el análisis a rusia también le
hasta el oído de manera muy concreta
para también afianzar cierta identidad
nacional y cierto orgullo nacional que
para entender a putin también y para
tender liderazgo de putin hay que
entender lo que sucedió durante la
década de los 90 con con injerencia y
tras la integración de la unión
soviética todo el caos todo el desorden
que hubo la la gran desigualdad el
surgimiento de las mafias también de los
oligarcas etcétera etcétera entonces el
conflicto con la guerra con ucrania que
les sirve para esto y no sólo para poner
enemigos agrarias sino básicamente un
enemigo que es todo occidente no y esto
se refuerza también cuando uno ve las
sanciones que van más allá del gobierno
ruso inclusive afectan a ciudadanos
rusos de a pie que no tiene nada que ver
quizás con este gobierno inclusive
quizás algunos pueden ser disidentes
pero se les prohíbe viajar se les
prohíbe ser turistas en algunos países
por lo menos alguna unos pedidos en este
tendido entonces eso hace que sea siento
sentimiento nacionalista y algo similar
pasa en ucrania siendo por supuesto a
rusia como como enemigo y siendo se más
hacia el lado occidental no es una
profundización de lo que sucedió durante
lo que fue el euro maldad donde los
jóvenes más próxima les empezaron a
exigir reforma antes arona a pedir
cambios políticos concretos su país es
pero estamos viendo hoy y está claro que
en lo que respecta el soft pauer
terminar josep-maria poder blando no
respecto de sobre todo por lo menos en
occidente
ucrania lleva claramente la delantera en
este sentido porque cuenta con el apoyo
de los principales países occidentales y
también los principales medios ejemplo
de esto fue por ejemplo gestión de fotos
de selenski y su esposa para la revista
de moda de vogue la semana que funciona
si la visita de
presidentes y dignatarios
internacionales que han llegado aquí
para respaldar
y el rumbo que le ha dado selenski a
este conflicto desde que me queda un
minuto para finalizar el programa
rápidamente la conclusión iván de cómo
ve usted lo que se viene para los
siguientes meses que es justamente el
invierno sin gas y sin petróleo ruso en
europa
hay un elemento que debemos tomar en
cuenta en américa latina'
y es como estos países que dependen del
turismo como es el caso de los países
que estamos en las zonas del caribe
si la locomotora de la unión europea que
es alemana se ve obligada a cerrar
empresas
qué va a suceder con esos turistas que
vienen a nuestros países cuáles son los
efectos colaterales que esta situación
va a presentar
evidentemente que la guerra de ucrania
nos muestra un panorama
caótico y sobre todo
angustiante claro que no vemos luz al
final del túnel no hay una solución
militar
para esta guerra es política pues a
gonzalo y ahí van les agradezco por este
análisis para la audiencia de france 24
6 meses esta historia continúa la
seguiremos analizando aquí en el debate
de france 24 por supuesto ustedes muchas
gracias por la sintonía pueden seguir
dejando todos sus comentarios en las
redes sociales
[Música]